good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a Tuesday dark
and gray in New York but we are happy
sunny and bright we are back in studio
we were in Philadelphia yesterday but we
did release a podcast episode so make
sure you check it out it was a quickie
but really quite hilarious but if you're
here you might as well stay here because
we have a fresh episode for you today
filled with so much freshness it's fresh
just like us we are unfresh I took a
shower I took a shower and did you wash
your hair of course he's like I washed
my hair yesterday for the first time
since I got it done in Nashville which
actually isn't like a huge length of
time for me but I did so much and I had
so much gunk in it from Nashville like
it was already like sticky situation but
I powered through most the situation I
didn't even have any time to like do it
again I just had the craziest busiest
weekend and I'm not one for like
traveling and being busy and you're not
I'm much more for you know like law and
order and just being sedentary and all
of that so it was it was a big weekend
for your girl but we made it through are
you tired
um I am tired except I went to bed so
late last night because I started
watching botched and I just couldn't
stop I don't like live for Bob but it's
that good I never was like so obsessed
with it and I'm still not fit you see
the beginning of the episode it's just
like house hunters for you and then you
have to see how it goes oh I disagree
like I will skate right past Fox like if
I'm watching Kardashians or something in
that an episode of bachi comes on like
this second I see Terry Dubrow space I'm
like get me the [ __ ] out of here team
but then I the second I see a woman with
one tip and one note it yeah with it a
size D and a negative a well I'm in I
went to camp with a girl who actually
had two different sized breasts and it's
like everyone is - no but she had like a
crazy a and a double date no but this
woman had gotten implants because like
both of them and she ever loved cheated
on her with like women with bigger boobs
and she realizes now that's like not a
good reason but she got implants and one
of the boot breasts like didn't take her
she had thin breast tissue so she's been
living eight years with one implant in
and one no boo oh at least she wasn't
born that way this curly went to camp I
was born that way yeah you know what I
was interested in I would like to see an
episode of botched natural botched by
Nature
yeah bbm you know because sometimes it's
like we just villainized these other
surgeons that they went to and I'm just
curious you know to see and sometimes
the other searches that made it so bad
that there's no more cartilage to work
with right right but it would be
interesting to see a BBN since weird
things people who were born with yeah
also are interesting then looks like you
feel bad for them yeah so hard to feel
bad for someone about a botched botched
boob job it's like you pay for that but
here's someone to feel bad for someone
who went to get a boob job and the
surgeon gave her a nose job and what
gave her like the worse nose ever that's
what I watch sucks was he evil are like
to talk well in the words of Terry
Dubrow your old surgeon was a
supervillain but dr. Nassif is a
superhero oh wow they are really just
like a great duo like a complement each
other I feel like they're both really
thirsty and want to be the star of the
show
but in a lot of ways they both are the
stars of the shows and I think it's
actually like a good formula and
structure for them because I think had
it not been they could have been like
eating at each other like kidding they
also roast each other and it's clear
that they're true friends yeah and
thirst and in work and honestly all that
makes me think is that if I ever get I'm
sorry when I get plastic surgery I want
to go to dr. Dubrow Shamus the change
right
I just mean dr. Dubrow I don't know what
I would do with dr. nassif what um what
surgeries are thinking about getting in
the future like when your breasts
breasts yeah I'm getting a lift or a
reduction like the second I'm done how
many children like the next day yeah I'm
going from labor then you take me out of
the hospital like keep me honest at all
and then have dr. Dubrow come and do my
titties like I want small perky titties
that like look like a deer like I don't
even want like a little teardrop no like
I want them so [ __ ] straight like
they actually are looking up okay no but
I just I also just want them so small
that like I can be like a grandma with
side boob yes yes I'm very much one side
boob like I do not want to wear a bra
ever again I've been wearing a bra
literally since I was 10 and I don't
even take it off I only take it off to
shower and even in the shower I'm like
holding my tits up like I will no I will
the day I get a breast reduction and I'm
very much afraid of like anesthesia and
like all that stuff but I don't give a
[ __ ] like I will die on the table just
just for an attempt to get titties that
stand up on their own you know help my
famous tweet about how my arm strength
comes from blow-drying my hair and
taking selfies that has changed it's
also died it comes from holding up my
breasts at all times like I have a
killer this must meet you know I'm whole
and by the way you only need one arm to
hold up your titties if you're a real B
TT big to BTC big titty committee member
you know that you really only need one
arm to hold up both breasts it's kind of
a talent you know like can you put a
pencil
Nathan my [ __ ] I could put you it's
like you pass the test with the pencil
like [ __ ] is it maids great yeah you
know it's so it's to be like I hate
having big that is the funniest no but
it's really so true people I like it was
so bad I can fit a bunch so like a
pencil I can fit I can fit the Oh
literally like oh my god I hate having
big titties and like people who don't
have it they're like I wish I had big
titties and then it's like people have
big titties always wish he had small
titties and people who have small
titties always wish they had big titties
but I'm here to tell you people with
small titties like you're wrong okay
you're dead wrong to our dead [ __ ]
wrong it's like the only reason people
with small titties want big titties it's
like so boys will like this woman that's
a terrible [ __ ] reason and like you
need to evaluate your life choices
before getting your tits made bigger ya
know a hundred percent it's only for the
men it's like if they're diving cute I
really want to actually take a look at
stassi's boobs I know she had mention
that she got a reduction right yeah a
reduction on the left I believe I want
to see what it looks like because they
showed on this show like her before she
botched no no no but on Vanderpump rules
talks about it and then they showed like
pic medical pictures of her before now
today oh I got a say just once but it
was interesting I had to go back take a
look yeah she's got a nice set yeah I
know I feel like she would she's like
she always did who is his real woman I
feel like she was like I could pass the
pencil test like it was time yeah yeah
but it's like that's like my bar is so I
like if you pass the pencil test to me
you still have small titties yeah
totally like I can't even begin to
relate to someone who thinks that
putting a pencil underneath their boobs
is like a big deal no like me said
there's a anyway it's like that's just
so normal like I can't even really I
can't anyway today's botched so I caught
up on all TV last night which we will
digest at the end of the show I caught
up on half the TV that you don't watch
and you caught up and half the TV that I
was too lazy to watch so we'll give it
all to you it'll be a well-rounded
episode um yesterday we talked to all
about Bravo cons so if you're interested
in our recap check check it out and then
today I watch watch it happens live so
I'll talk about that at the end also if
you miss there's so much new content we
had a great episode on Friday with
Mercedes Javid where she told us a lot
about Bravo Khan the new season of Shahs
of Sunset but then also we got a new
episode of this snatchler today where
they we kept a lot of the bachelor
ongoing drama you know lots of happening
you know how to be on Dancing with the
Stars lots of other stuff in addition to
what it's like just being like a
fabulous girl in New York so check out
the snapchat we got a new episode of
date
with Raven the atom that dropped
yesterday they are just so cute I can
listen to Ravens voice she should be I'm
calm or like one of those meditation
asks because she's such a great voice
I'm gonna get a new episode tomorrow a
mood with Lauren Elizabeth so there's
just like never-ending streams of
content when you're here it's a
supporter of the trust news network also
follow the Cho's news network on
Instagram
oh yeah Claudia is doing a great job
with it I'm just really fired like it's
my passion you know yeah and but like I
find that like a few days will go by and
like I'll forget to post and then I'm
like at the tub last night like making
contact you know that's the thing about
passions it's like it's not I mean it is
your job in this case but it's just
supposed to be there for you to be
passionate about like it's not supposed
to be like you're 95 and I don't want to
like post content just for the sake of
like saying I posted once a day right
it's like I want everything I say to
like have a purpose yeah like what what
are you saying what is your mood you
know yeah what is your me that was a
really problem I was so sad it was like
my mood last night was actually just
pure joy like I was in my bed like
nestled up in Theo's pit like I just
there were no words to describe like how
at home I felt I had I like I've been
traveling a lot like the past year or
whatever like this particular week was
probably one of the heart it's like from
Morocco to Nashville to Pittsburgh to
Philadelphia to bed like all within a
week it was just to be home you don't
really appreciate home so much like
until you leave for a while and I was
like smelling my walls I was like I love
it here so much ya know it's it's an
incredible feeling truly that was funny
cassio feels good you know bigger and
brighter than ever he's definitely
gained a little bit of weight and I
really don't care about that
like you badiy shamed him all the time
and that could actually really pisses me
off but actually I did notice that he
his belly is hanging like a little
closer to the floor like he's got a he
actually is like a food but just like
his mom I'm I'm on the case some of the
case okay good I'm glad to hear that
yeah I just hate to deprive him like
he's such a happy kid you know when he
does such like I feel like he thinks
he's being punished you know when he's
not ya know I it's okay it has to be
done you helped me better off and then
whole like have a summer body ready and
he'll just be taking the Hamptons by
storm again and yeah he wants to feel
his best you know he does want to look
at his friends and be like how come like
I can't wear skinny jeans you know he
can't that's a thing yeah I don't want
him to grow up in a world where it's
like you have to be a certain size to
wear skinny jeans that's what I'm saying
but it's everybody that is that's a
platform that I like will die off I know
but here's the thing it really isn't
even about how he looks because he's a
perfect angel and like he could look
whatever he should have been in the
Charlie's Angels reboot and will
to that but it's for his health yeah
whatever he was fun no and he just took
a DNA test and turns out he's a hundred
percent Russian Russian and it's great
yeah it's incredible anyways we have a
great show for you today so many
interesting stories I actually had a
hard time whittling them down that never
happens usually it's like we're scraping
the bottom of the barrel by the time we
get to the fourth story yeah but I'm I
look forward to getting into it because
there's much to discuss so I think
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's true
don't get me wrong it's definitely true
that it's time because I see the clock
10:41 definitely time but I would be
absolutely remiss devastated and
heartbroken if I didn't let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by one of our favorite brands here
at the morning toast
Sanford did you know that scent is the
most powerful since you have a smell can
bring on a flood of memories influence
your mood and of course enhance your
natural style very true whenever I smell
trouble I think about the time I throw
up on the side of Montauk Highway when I
was in the Hamptons like a few years ago
and I can no longer eat the pizza to
Sophia from Serafina
every time I smell something maple base
I think of my sister who has committed
to a maple based scent this season
thanks December while you're looking for
that signature scent that will make you
stand out and keep the memory of you
lingering on why waste so much time and
money with cheap knockoffs and
half-empty bottles of failed experiments
with 10 bird you can have a great taste
you can have great taste and mix up your
fragrance routine without breaking the
bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci or Versace
sent Burt calm keeps you smelling good
month after month so I have tried the
Bulgari perfume and I believe a Dior
perfume this week was a mountain goat
speak for me because Sandford just sent
over a few new flavors that's a new
fragrance that they have and honestly it
is apt that this episode is sponsored by
semper because this week was sponsored
by Sanford I had all these different
stem burns in my purse just spritzing
here and there smelling like a new
morning is traveling and not showering
like you best be having that temper
tonya when you're at a wedding in
Morocco and like you did not wash your
hair wands like you best be spritzing
that do you are [ __ ] yes bits on
your hair you know when you go from
Nashville to LA to Philadelphia to New
York and you didn't wash your hair one
time it is key that you do have a spritz
to spritz so sin burr is a luxury
fragrance subscription service for for
perfumes and colognes they have more
than 600 designer brands for you to
choose from
choose the perfume you want to try
they'll send you a 30 day supply then
the next month you could either keep
with it try a new one that way you
didn't waste a whole bottle on something
you might not have loved if you're not
sure what type of set you're looking for
you can sort and find your
new fragrance by brand style occasions
season and more plus they've products
from other categories like skincare
wellness and makeup they just started
carrying cope re which as you know is
one of our favorites here and if you're
ever looking for a chapstick that'll
change your life check out part yeah and
if you ever looking for your risk to be
snapped
check out snag syncope we also have
products from glam glow glow recipe tart
and many others so we have an exclusive
offer just for our listeners you can get
30% off with your first month that's
only $10 for your first fragrance the
offer has changed you guys so make sure
you're not using our old link it is
scent bird calm / steen and use the code
Steen for 30% of your first month that's
only $10 for your first fragrance so the
website is scent bird calm SCE MTBI our
d.com / steam ste en and the code is
Steen ste and for you to try your first
perfume or cologne for just $10 sign on
smell amazing let's get into it
love it okay our first story of the day
something that I was really excited to
talk about because as the Morning Post
predicted back when we were in Austin I
remember the episode Charlie's Angels
reboot has flopped no not only is it
flopped like it is flippity flop like a
fish okay it is fobba-liscious swamped
central wracked in just about nine
million dollars opening weekend it cost
50 million dollars to make I mean like
not shocking that it was blocked but
shocking at the actual numbers like
that's crazy
shocking that this is such a public flop
because Elizabeth Banks is taking to
Twitter she's coming up swinging to
discuss the floppiness and she said well
if you're going to have a flop make sure
your name is on it at least four times
she said I'm proud of Charlie's Angels
and happy it's in the world said only
Elizabeth Banks ever anyways she now an
interview is circulating where she she
basically should fill the Wall Street or
like The Wall Street Journal she
basically said that this movie flopped
because men don't want to see when
movies starring women and she blamed
them just like a misogynist culture
we've had 37 spider-man movies and like
they all do they don't want to see the
women in action
yeah as a woman I don't want to see this
movie either yeah I think this is like a
little bit of a cop-out like don't get
me wrong there's plenty of misogyny in
the world but the same it you know this
movie probably just stings and like
having a nobody play one of the three
angels was probably not your best having
a complete nobody with less Instagram
followers with me
I need you like that's not what this
movie was predicated on it was event
having Kristen Stewart be like the
anchor of it she's just not she's not
like personal enough to carry a
franchise on her back anymore and she's
a self-hating franchisee like Jackie
looks back at Bella Swan with disdain
like why would we want her in our next
franchise and let me just say I'm
married to a man who absolutely lives
for movies with girls like all he wants
to do is see movies I'm like you won't
see that like and he I don't even think
he knows that this movie existed like I
just think that this cop-out is not only
incorrect but it also like D values like
any real misogyny like yeah not why the
movie flopped or hey there's plenty of
movies that do really well with women in
it like and don't owe me wrong there's
plenty of movies that definitely don't
pass the Bechdel test like there there's
there's definitely a problem here and in
the movie industry Elizabeth Banks but I
just didn't think your movie is like the
crux of the problem I just think the
movie is actually like not good and
Charlie's Angels already has so many
built-in fans that all you needed was
three complete rockstars to play the
parts and like who people know and who
people love and they just missed it on
all counts yeah it was and also I don't
really think that the marketing was very
good because the marketing was
incredible they were everywhere really I
didn't get any like ariana grande doing
the soundtrack like they had all
different trailers and from the minute
everyone saw the first trailer ourselves
included and that song came out that
nobody asked where it was like this is a
piece of garbage oh yeah man hey Donna
so but you know me back 10200 I know
don't call me just like the more I sing
it to myself the more I like it
look I'm sad that this flops because it
would've been a great moment for women
but please don't let in the fact that
there are women in it as to the reason
it wasn't good like really nobody asked
for this reboot nobody wanted it and
therefore nobody saw here's the thing
I'm sad that this is a bad movie and I
and I know that it's a bad news yeah no
I don't need to see it to be and there's
so many there's so many great women that
could have been in this movie and who
have like built-in audiences I was
actually watching Knightley pop last
night and I was they were talking about
this story and they were saying who they
would want in a movie and Morgan said
Margot Robbie which was literally but I
said you know her and then Nina said
Lupita Nyong'o
which one or me sadder that in the car
when they heard they said they would
keep Kristen Stewart aside she has a
vibe about her
can edgy like whatever but like when you
think of actual Charlie's Angels like
none of them really give me like Kristen
survives like they're all like no like
she's their bubbly yeah right she's kind
of dark and like bold so well definitely
you could have had like the token bold
edgy angel you definitely needed a few
bubbly effervescent angels I think
Lupita Nyong'o would have been great
yeah oh you couldn't got even younger
someone is suggesting dove Cameron's end
day and Lily Reinhart oh wait like we're
like a Sabrina carpenter we just I have
judged they should have plucked from
like the Disney and like made a couple
stars out of it like some Sophia
Carson's like that actually have been
great I would just I mean zendaya like
you just put tenday in any movie and
she's a star obviously that's the Miss
here yeah and so I was thinking about
it's like there has to be a person to
blame for this casting nightmare and
this atrocity and honestly it's a listen
to thing yeah I know and but which is
shocking because she's really on the
pulse of like culture like she does
pitch perfect she gave us pitch perfect
and she's actually like a secret behind
the scenes person I'm like a lot of
content that you don't realize and that
you actually love so I find it shocking
that she was so much a part of this and
since she's tweeting about it was
obvious that this was like really a
passion project if her doesn't like I
feel sad for her yeah I do feel sad for
her but I couldn't
like I just I don't know how they didn't
see this coming you know yeah because
ever since the trailer came out like
nobody was excited no it's so crazy how
like there was so much marketing for it
but nobody was talking about it right so
when I saw Kristen Stewart on Jimmy
Fallon I remember I said I watched one
episode of Jimmy Fallon and I just think
it was really like in like an indicator
of like how poor that movie was gonna be
because she was so not bubbly and then
even mentioned with it which was they're
promoting like it was so weird
this height with this suggestion Lana
candor zendaya Lilly Reinhardt love it
love it that's the next reboot that we
need yeah but like I feel like now
they've really tainted the Charlie's
Angels name like Charlie's Angels was so
precious because like no one it's just
like it's a good movie like it and that
was it you know such a good movie and
honestly I wouldn't be so upset about
this if I hadn't just re-watched the
Cameron Diaz Drew Barrymore and Lucy Liu
one and I I literally watched you two
weeks ago and I was obsessed with it and
I can't believe they did this so dirty
and I just feel like they just need to
skip over this movie kind of like they
need to skip over Prince Charles and I
just go straight to Will and Kate and I
shape your knowledge a straight to
zendaya Lana and yeah Lee love it ZL el
cielo okay cool well the next story is
like so
bizarre and like such non news but it's
being treated like you know the moon
landing I need to know what you're
talking about Bella Hadid me Lina go man
well you know what I know you think it's
a nothing burger but I actually find it
to be very interesting
okay take us through what happened so
Selena Gomez and Bella Hadid before me
look before we even talk about what
happened like let's talk about their
connection they both used to date the
weekend and they kind of overlapped like
it's definitely there's definitely
weirdness there mm-hmm also Selena is
best time to tell the chef who's best
service Gigi who's Belle sister so like
there is a connection there but I don't
think I've ever seen Bella and Selena in
the same room right so they should have
beef but they also should be friends so
it's like it's unclear where they stand
and then last week Selena Gomez who has
been so [ __ ] active on Instagram
followed Bella Hadid Bella Hadid did not
follow her back then Bella Hadid put up
a picture of herself like looking back
you Selena Gomez commented stunning
Bella deleted the picture so it's like
we're not gonna think she'd to leave the
whole picture of Kristalina Gomez comes
in on it but it's definitely weird and
then a fan account posted that the
Selena Gomez comment and saying like
Bella deleted it because of the cops
yes saying like she's all about
supporting women you all just can't take
it nicely I might miss it miss Addie
deleted the post Selena commented on
that that sucks
cry emoji so like Selena's just being so
active and so weird and like honestly
the way that she is like posting is
making me think that there's weirdness
yeah but TMZ has an article saying they
have sources and I honestly believe
their sources that there's no beef yeah
but like why everything was fine until
Selena Gomez commented on that pan
account I understand why Bella made us
leave that photo like I think it's a
Dior it's a Dior Addict maybe there was
you know some FTC knows like it says to
do your thing and she's a sponsor for
Dior so maybe like you delete photos
sometimes when they just like don't go
up the way you wanted them to her like
they didn't work with the flow I don't
know
but then Selena Gomez commenting on a
fan account that sucks and like
perpetuating this narrative that like
Bella Hadid deleted the comment being
deleted the whole picture because it
were a comment like it's very it's weird
also TMZ has alleged that Bella actually
reached out to Selena like behind the
scenes letting her know that like
everything was okay so I just don't know
why Selena's being like so active and
like acting like kind of like a loser
here you can victim like yeah like she
like relaxed well it's almost like it's
an Instagram comment like why are we
acting
this is like realize these negotiations
also like let's talk about it like there
definitely is some weirdness between
Celine and Bella like yeah and they both
dated the weekend so close to each other
like I actually think he might have
cheated on but like it was so much
overlap like and maybe just because like
we find everything out like a little bit
late in the public but like their
relationships were like so close in
terms of time like it has to believe
like maybe he was like fooling around
with one of us maybe but also is like he
went from Bella to Selena back to Belet
him and Bella might still might be
together right now unclear and so like
she's just as excellent yeah I would I
be why wouldn't his ex be coming on my
picture it's really honored and if it
weren't for the connection of like Gigi
and Taylor like I would think it's even
weirder but like I guess in some circles
like they would be considered like they
should be friends I don't per haps but I
don't think that Bella and Taylor are
like no not at all actually which is so
weird because Bella and Gigi are so
close yeah and Gigi and Taylor so close
and honestly Belen Gigi likes share the
same circle of friends like real friends
my celebrity friends so you would think
that applies like to celebrity friends
but it doesn't because I don't think
I've literally ever seen Bella in the
same room as Taylor's web team yeah I
think they're just they're just
different
is there any like Bella Taylor drama
that I can think of like and they feel
like a cage it's Gigi who's able to be
friends with everyone the best friends
with Kendall and she's best friends with
Taylor so I don't think Belen Taylor sup
have like anything in common no I don't
think they've ever met more than that I
don't aside from the weekend I don't
think that and Selena Gomez have
anything in common if I were about with
Hadid I wouldn't like Selena Gomez no me
neither and if I was Bella Hadid and it
actually has nothing to do with the
weekend I just know I just think they're
like different people yeah and I feel
like Bella it's only not really friends
with Taylor cuz I couldn't think of two
more different people in my life you
know like no shade they're just like
different yeah and I feel like Bella
wouldn't wanna hang out at Taylor and
Taylor one wanting out they'll initiate
they just like different strokes for
different folks yeah do you Selena Gomez
like does her own Instagram and writes
her own comments well so it depends I
think now that she has these new two new
songs out and she's obviously in a much
better headspace I do think she's
writing her on Instagram but like when
she was putting up a random selfie in
than a coach ad it was like weekend at
Bernie's someone like propping her up
and using her fingers to type like just
to get into her iPhone like use her
thumb so now I think she runs her own
Instagram and she was definitely one
leading these comments but I think for
the past like two years it wasn't I
don't think I'm gonna go out and say I
don't think she's writing these comments
I think she has a social media team like
I I don't think she likes Instagram I
just like wanted letting her social
media team comment on a fan account like
something that I think this social
but the social media team they're the
experts like Selena doesn't tell them
what to do like dare telling or you
think this is out or running your grant
a hundred percent in like so they're
commenting lifting up other women who
they think she would be like you know in
feuding with I would be weird no I I
don't think it's actually her because
she doesn't like Instagram at all I mean
you could always tell when a celebrity
doesn't run their Instagram account it's
like so like every picture it's like a
quote card like it's so manufacturers
also when in between I think there are
celebrities who have input on their
Instagram they probably send their
agency some family photos sometimes and
like they make it look more familiar but
I think there are like agencies at
hardcore pretend to be pretend to be the
celebrities they comment on pictures
like and they they build the brand up
because the celebrity they're making
movies they don't think about these
things
yes they are working on their art I
don't know Selena Gomez it just doesn't
seem like that to me but maybe I mean
I'm gonna guess she's always like taking
a break and like it's she doesn't [ __ ]
with it yeah but I don't know I'm not
convinced I'm convinced that she's like
that she had nothing to do with this
that we crazy like she's making news and
like doesn't even know because it's
someone on her team like being an idiot
ya know but they're not being me because
now it's in TMZ and everyone's talking
about has Selena it's so stunning
we're always fun it's like Bella like
that is nice and Hello looks mean and
that's news making I guess and some
people are talking about something other
than like her mysterious two-year
absence you know yeah which which one
for you yeah well never forget okay next
story I found to me quite interest on
I'm just gonna take a sip of coffee
because I'm thirsty okay so while you do
that let me just tell everyone that
today's episode is also brought to you
by society6 if you're looking for a
thoughtful unique gift this holiday
season you need to check out society6 we
got a gift box sent to the studio what
your hump is not good no oh I'm sorry I
don't know if it's like not enough milk
I didn't have ice and we got a huge gift
box from society6 it is some of the
cutest
decor and honestly it's very toasty they
have like I want to say like over 50
items that are just toasty day core like
with the leaf it's really really cute
they have a community of 350 thousand
independent artists from around the
world so you can find everything from
wall art and furniture to home decor and
lifestyle accessories and it's super
unique stuff that you're not going to
find anywhere else no matter who you're
shopping for if you're sure to find a
perfectly unique gift for everyone on
your list every society6 purchase pays
an artist which is the best part it's no
you know big conglomerate you know
corporate America [ __ ]
I'm the empowered creativity across the
world by allowing artists to keep doing
what they love there are literally
millions of designers for you to choose
from
you can you are sure to find something
you love they have a huge array of
products from wall art to throw pillows
to yoga mats foam cases and wrapping
paper I got a ton of cute throw pillows
that are very toasty and cute acrylic
trades which is like you're always
looking for like a little tchotchke like
tray things they have a ton of ChaCha
it's basically tchotchkes that job um
it's your go-to place to shop for
creative gifts for everyone in your life
they're custom-made just for you you can
choose what you love society6 makes it
to order and ships it directly to you
it's nice to know that your gift was
designed by an independent artist and
not just grabbed from a shelf in a
warehouse but crafted by an actual
person if you want to give a thoughtful
and unique gift this holiday season do
it with society6 you can get 30% off and
free shipping when you use our code
toast at s6 dotco slash toast again that
link is s6 dot KO slash toast and the
promo code is toast society6 design your
everyday with art you love s-six KO
slash toast promo code toast
check it out of it sang on get cute chit
ok this story interesting fashion
editors beg for mindful awareness from
gif happy gift happy brands huh a group
of fashion editors has taken a brave
stand to save the planet fashion editors
are so brave I think that's like page
six being um sardonic by asking luxury
brands to let them pick their own
Christmas gifts the journalist had
posted a manifesto on Instagram
honestly that reads quote in an effort
to reduce excess we in the fashion
community are seeking a mindful
awareness this holiday season and beyond
we urge PR agencies and brands to
refrain from blind gifting and using
excessive unboxing materials honestly I
don't hate this no me neither I'm sorry
I take back everything I just said I
couldn't agree more
the band of eco-warriors suggests it
might be best for you know the sea
otters of editors could instead pick
their own gifts or as they put it in the
note be offered a choice of product a
cynic might read the solace to send us
the card EA but you can skip the festive
popcorn gifts oh yeah by the way it
sounds like pretentious but as someone
who gets like limited by gifting from
brands I'm PR agencies like I don't even
get a lot I think in comparison to like
my peers it's so wasteful like not only
for the actual like paper that they send
it in like the tissue paper the peanuts
the boxes this leaves like it's so
wasteful definitely so bad for the
environment
I fill up my garbage room I'm like this
is so stupid but also the actual product
like no human being needs every single
foundation shade like I'm not like tan
or and I'm not blackout like and it's
like why don't they just send foundation
to people who actually need that
certainty or just pick your colour like
Ivan is so wasteful from the actual
packaging and then to the actual product
like it's such a waste I'm like I do
what I can like and donate and I gave it
I literally give half my makeup to my
doorman he has a daughter who's obsessed
with YouTube and like they gave her
jeffree star palette like her life
change and it's like it's so nice but
like it's so wasteful it's so weak and
it sounds like such a first-person prop
for a small problem but it's not no it's
it's so true I feel that I think this
all the time and year-round - and I know
like their tape they're being extreme
and I feel like a lot of these fashion
editors like they just want to be able
to pick the handbag they're gonna get so
they don't get like one that they don't
like and then they have to go and sell
it on eBay but I think in general a lot
of these PR packages they are so
wasteful with all the crap and then I
put all that crap in my garden each room
and recycle it and then it's a go - I
even have a couple lipsticks I aren't
even shades I would wear ya know it's so
silly and I feel like PR and gifting has
gone so out of control and I was
actually just watching another Jeffrey
star video yesterday and like I get that
he's like probably he's the biggest the
most influential person in the beauty
community but like the amount of boxes
in his house is so crazy it's like it
really is such a like a wasteful and
definitely like a problem for our
environment yeah and it's like it's
stupid no one needs that much of
anything that's what it is it's like
also it's a necessity thing like don't
get me wrong some of the stuff I get
from PR lift or keep sending it but like
some of the stuff people send them like
I didn't even ask for it I don't even
know how they got my address and it's
actually kind of scary and it's like I
didn't even ask for this I don't want
this and now it's like what do I do with
it yeah it's so wasteful it's so silly
and it's like you're not even helping
your brand because like I didn't even
ask for this you know yeah sometimes
don't get me wrong I'm reaching out on
my tart hey I need a couple more shaped
tapes like there's something I need ya
know but like sometimes something that
someone they'll do a new collection they
send you everything from the collection
and it's like I won't even wear this
stuff like it's better off going to
someone else maybe they just asked me if
there's anything from that collection
that I want and then right I'll be so
exciting to have anywhere and the
collection is made for a wide range of
people a wide range of skin tones a wide
range of sizes like whatever it is so
it's like not one person needs into our
collection right because the point of a
collection is that it's for different
people
yeah but it's more like it's close and
especially at this time of year
stuff would be so much better don't eat
it oh my god totally breads are so wait
saw I mean I just wanna say I think I
was ahead of the curve like two years
ago I did you know a whole challenge I
really took like the world by storm it's
called the holiday makeup challenge like
I get so much Becky makeup by the time I
would even get to use it it's expired
like it just sits in my in my thing so I
donated it at all and a bunch of
influencers followed like I didn't
really catch on because like I feel like
influencers are like I'll chew in their
own hat but I did try like I just wanna
say I was the first eco warrior here you
were I have a pile of makeup that's like
I'm building it up and then I'm gonna
donate it I found a great company to
work with I think doing like working
with different I'd like bottomless
closet I think they're great but it's
like by the time like let's say someone
I wear makeup everyday like
hypothetically all the makeup I get for
free like I could use it but it's like
by the time I've actually got to it by
the time I'm done with this concealer
like and I have four more by the time I
get to the fourth one like it's most
likely expired yeah it's like such a
[ __ ] waste yeah it's so stupid like
no one can actually go through all the
product that they get yeah in a lifetime
even me why literally wear makeup every
day yeah no same it's so so and by the
way like wear the same thing every day
and so you sending me like a new shade
of lipstick like it's really nice but
won't wear it I'm not moving away from
this Tarte you know yeah and I think a
lot of people we're good about donating
it and I think a lot of influencers are
conscious or conscious but the brands
themselves can be conscious and that's
the point I totally agree that's it yeah
it's just the point right it's like
you're right exactly that's a very
interesting story I'm sorry that I made
fun of these people like for being brave
this is actually like a good call
yeah okay next story I was and also an
interesting story a lawsuit claims
Burger King's impossible whoppers are
contaminated by me what Burger King was
sued on Monday by a vegan customer who
would okay like this vegan customer is
just like the reason people hate being
so true who accused the fast-food chains
of chain of contaminating its meatless
impossible whoppers by cooking them on
the same grills as its traditional meat
burgers in a proposed class-action
Philip Williams said he bought an
impossible whopper a plant-based
alternative and in Atlanta drive-thru I
would not have paid a premium price had
he known the cooking wouldn't leave it
quote coated in meat byproducts oh my
god this guy's chewing like this is why
this is why like okay this is a crazy
example I mean this is what's wrong with
our country I'll never forget I was at a
bar once and these two people were
beating up this guy and there was a
security guard standing there but he
couldn't get involved
because like we're so litigious that
like he did want to get suit if it's
something ended up happening to victim
and it's like this guys are getting
beaten up nobody can do anything because
our society is so delicious
this guy feel up it's a problem I mean
because he bought a burger that he
didn't like yes so he wants he's seeking
damages and he also wants Burger King to
plainly disclose that impossible walkers
and regular burgers are cooked on the
scene grills also I'd look at this for
like being a kosher person the rules of
being kosher is like if you're a kosher
meat is cooked on the same pan or the
same grill as non kosher that kosher
meat automatically becomes unco sure
because it's contaminated
I don't know vegan rules are uh strict
you know and I don't think a very strict
kosher person would be going to Burger
King anyway if you're that strict of a
vegan person like you shouldn't be
eating at Burger King right you wouldn't
be eating at a place that sells non
vegan stuff like a kosher person would
not even consider something kosher but
it wouldn't be a like Burger King
wouldn't be a kosher restaurant at all
because they know in the product that
they're selling that is kosher wouldn't
be even considered kosher because it's
being sold at an encore establishment
right so it's like someone's that strict
they wouldn't even be eating at Burger
King because it's not a completely
plant-based establishment right this
person tells like such a weenie like oh
my god I could die and it's because
you're vegan like no offense like I
understand it's a you know it's a
decision that you've made but you're
gonna be okay right with meat by-product
like that knowing I just gotta say bro I
had an SAT tutor who was vegan and she
came to our house she had a soup that
she had gotten and she said you mind if
I eat my soup I said no of course there
are you gonna your soup and I guess
there must have been something you know
non vegan products in it she painted the
shock of eating vegan she said that she
was starting to not feel good well is
she allergic to me I don't know but she
said she's vegan and she felt like there
was some non vegan products in the soup
and she dip it in our house and I was
all alone and I've never been so scared
in my whole life here's the thing now
you know they're cooked on the same
grill make your own choices yeah now you
know Philip William you're not vegan but
you don't eat meat so now that you know
that it might be next to or near some
pride buy products made of meat
what do you have to say he's so neat
it's not yes I will still eat it I am
NOT a strict kosher as I'm like you know
kosher should be but for me like it's
like a mental thing and I
I will lead it yeah I agree but you make
your own decisions okay Philip Williams
what kind of engine damaged it because
you had meat byproducts you said over
four dollars back is that what you want
yeah then give him his four dollars back
Burger King look if he wins I'll be so
upset like this is [ __ ] yeah what
kind of damages could you seek mental
instability like I don't understand so
frustrating like then it like takes away
from people like like someone who got a
finger in their Wendy's you know like
that's real like you see for that 100%
girls that a mouse in her Starbucks they
they described the impossible burger as
100% whopper 0% beef and adds up for
guests looking for a meat free option a
non boiler method of preparation is
available upon request oh so you can't
ask them and then you get your Myka your
thing gets put in the microwave so enjoy
yep you don't get pay there in real
market love whatever you may develop
Williams um just come on like everyone
is such a complainer no like be cool
come on just like roll with it or okay
whoa they're cooked on the same grill
and I'm not cool with that you'll go
back moving on
amen amen or why don't you try an envoy
Euler method of preparation yeah my god
Philip geez Louise this is like he's
Attica he was so blame like oh my god be
cool don't be uncool like then they'll
take away impossible whoppers for right
it's not what you want what you want you
want a bankrupt Burger King so that US
vegans now have no options like come on
finally some justice for some
plant-based eaters and you're ruining it
Philip so true oh my god there's always
one guy who wears it oh my god [ __ ]
Philip this is why we can't have nice
plant-based things this is why we can't
have nice plant-based things because he
breaks them and then you take them away
this is what we do all day yeah okay see
the Minow story really sad switching
years james Van Der Beek reveals his
wife Kimberly suffered a miscarriage
last night on Dancing with the Stars
quote we lost the baby so literally
Jackie it was the saddest episode of
gentleman stars let me just walk you
through I mean I saw snitches stories
and then I called her so I I got the
lowdown and I was really sad there were
five people left and next week is the
finale so I guess only four couples go
to the finale which I didn't know cuz
like I said I'm new to Dancing with the
Stars so we have Kel Mitchell left
Lauren Alaina Hannah brown james Van Der
Beek enalopril and so they all danced
once it was obvious that those first
dances were pre-recorded because they're
all instagramming in their second
outfits and then all like the real T
came out in the second
so like everyone had like a story I'm a
sever Lauren Elena
so she was just basically saying like
she's still happy to be here and like
her parents really sacrificed everything
for her to be a singer like the fact
that she's here is all because of her
parents she was dancing for her parents
it was so sweet it's so sweet helmut
chilled was dancing um first friend Sam
who got involved in gang violence and
it's like how much I grew up and you
know on the wrong side of the tracks but
theater and like going on tour with like
this production like he was like part of
us like kids things like really like
helped keep him out of trouble but his
friend Sam wasn't so lucky and his
friend Sam and he's been really fighting
just like he said you know love wins
like you know jumping up the gun and it
was really beautiful and everyone really
liked it got a perfect score and
honestly like he's such a good dancer
and he's gotten there
he's it on to the finals based strictly
on his merits because like I don't think
he has like a cult following that's
voting for him ten times you know online
and on and be a text I mean I've been
for him have you
and then voting for Whitney oh and then
Jackie the craziest thing happened
Hannah brown
Hannah round came on and of course I
wouldn't hear this part from since no
and honestly I was reading people's
comments and like everyone's on her side
and like I'm I'm not not on her side but
like I just can't believe how much we
treat her like an actual two-year-old
like give it to me
so everyone the the premise of this week
was that everyone got a judge to come in
and help them because everyone was doing
the dance that they struggled with the
most so whether it was a somber the
tango so big she got Carrie Carrie Anne
and again like a few weeks ago Carrie I
was like a little harsh on her but like
Carrie Anne as a judge and like that's
literally her job so Carrie Anne comes
in and just starts telling Hannah like
you have to wait you have to do your hip
and then the arm like Hannah was doing
it wrong and Carrie Anne was correcting
her and literally how started crying
being like I just feel like I'm being
like attacked and carry on felt so bad
Carrie Anne started crying when Carrie I
was just doing her [ __ ] job
it was just like everyone by the way
everyone gets critiqued by the judges
and I had was like I just feel mine's
more personal like know everyone and by
the way of all the people hannah has had
the easiest time on the show like she
has gotten the best score she's never
been in the bottom like she's arguably
one of the best answers like she's had
the easiest time like people are Ally
Brooke is [ __ ] scraping her chance
like just to get like and Hannah it's
just like flowing through and and
complaining I couldn't believe it like
she was literally crying and Carrie Anne
felt so bad Carrie and literally her
voice cracked and she started to cry
shaking no when you feel like I'm
attacking you like I'm a judge like I'm
just doing my job judging you so then
Hannah dance and then Hannah actually
said um before she got her score she was
like carry on apologizes we made it seem
like I was she had real self awareness
Hannah she was
I want to make it seem like if I made
really feel bad for like being a judge I
just like was having a bad day totally
fine but like the way that people were
like why she's a star to show and she's
universally beloved why and she she
needed to move her hip right yeah and
then like her story was like you know
she fell in love and she just keeps
saying like what I've been through that
it's like well you've been through like
you're a star like and okay so you'll
have a boyfriend like so a lot of people
don't have a boyfriend like I just think
know what you've been through is that
you're single right it's like I just I I
literally can feel bad for it's like and
what's so crazy it's like everyone it's
like I'm like you know like she's about
to be a millionaire like she's
definitely in the show and like her
life's gonna change forever like
whatever like and then james Van Der
Beek and it's like it just puts in
perspective how dumb what everyone else
except not Cal but like really hug down
my kind of complaining when it's like
james Van Der Beek comes on he's like I
really wasn't opposed to dance like it's
what today's Monday said on Saturday
like his wife miscarried and she had
been at the show like she was pret like
showing like so sad he was crying and he
was like obviously was gonna dance but
my wife was like he got his yes and it's
like James has never been in the bottom
two
he's I would say either him or Hannah
are gonna win he goes home
I was Chuck so he left his wife's
bedside in the hospital just to get sent
home like okay who made this decision
okay here's what happened he was in the
bottom two with Allie Brooke this is
maybe heard her fourth time the bottom
two she is always in the bottom two but
she's always in the bottom two with
someone who stinks so it's like she
always get saved and the way that you
get saved is that the judges will vote
so the first judge is like I'm gonna
save Ali I'm like okay they're making a
tiebreaker they're gonna make it
dramatic and kerri-anne is like I'm
gonna save Ali I'm like what
it's over Ali felt so awkward she was
crying me like I give to James gotta
give these names it made no sense first
of all they should have just let him
stay because he literally left his
wife's bedside like just just to be a
nice Coptic prophets - they should've
made him stay because he's a better
dancer and I was husband and obviously
didn't do a great job this week because
his mind was elsewhere like he Ali has
been in the bottom countless times he's
never been the bottom he's always at the
top he gets the best chorus he's beloved
like it made no sense
that's insane it was crazy and so
awkward and then the episode just like
and did and it's like we were left with
like this emptiness snitch told me what
they didn't like I'm so weird it was
disgusting think it's unfair we're like
even if he was a bad dancer they should
have kept him but he never should have
been like oh one because let's just feel
bad for him and give him that and two
he's the best dancer like it made from
the first week he's with the best answer
and is so weird and makes no sense
so now Hana is 100% gonna win like James
does her only real I think competition
that's crazy
damn these shows are tough like Lauren
Elena it's just up there with as good of
a dancer but like the world is obsessed
with Hannah it's crazy so it's and like
Ally Brooke also just as good a dancer
cow milk Justin but I think Cal could
take it off tell is so good especially
like for a dude like he's really good
but it's like Hannah has this thing and
it's like they're really positioning her
to way and you could tell like by the
press and the instagrams like they're
just like setting her up to it yeah
she's just like the darling yeah which
sucks feels like she has the snitch on
her side cuz I'm done Lauren Alaina
steam she's doing so good she's looking
so [ __ ] good but she's looking like
this now just show it's gonna be the
best thing that ever happened to her
first of all her Instagram is literally
doubled in size she's almost at 900,000
she's looking so if I can snatch she's
like a darling like everyone gets it
she's so funny and like genuine in her
packages so she's like makes a little
joke but then it's like you know she's
talked about her upbringing she's just
like so American like people I think are
really gonna like love her after this
yeah she was this was a great thing I
wouldn't love if she was me - yeah she
has what it takes but I don't I don't
know if it's I don't believe it so it's
not about skill at this point because
everyone's talented so yeah it's not
politics yep totally matter [ __ ]
[ __ ] um okay recapping TV I
watch watch what happens live the
one-hour special seventy seven stars
thank God it was an hour yeah it was
really good they did a really good job
bringing everyone out in shifts we had
two performances right we had a
performance by Kim and LuAnn no when did
her show like her cabaret show later in
the evening but it wasn't like on TV or
anything um and yeah it was cute
everyone really got asked one question
unless you were part of like the games
they did like squashing Bravo beef
between like cross pollinating it was
really just fake Ramona and everyone and
I I don't like obviously I don't agree
with Ramona in even in these situations
but I just like everyone just roast her
in the crowd was like booing her and I
think she's looking like six
one years old she doesn't want to take a
picture sixty-two birthday today like
she and she she was had beef with
Giselle because at that time she like
kicked her out of the picture at that
event in the Hamptons yeah and she was
just saying I wanted a picture with the
host first it's like she but like also
Ramona's not like of this scope girl
like she doesn't understand like photo
etiquette like she's just like lives in
a world where it's like I met at a
benefit I want a picture with the host
yeah you know she doesn't like look
around her and then she do her loris was
had beef with her because one time after
watch what happens live Ramona wouldn't
take a picture with Frank Catania and
she was like I was tired I wanted to go
home and Delores was like why did you
choose this life then it's like she's
something 61 leave her alone oh my god
that's actually like so sad but don't
get me wrong we're wrong about us
totally a [ __ ] yeah shouldn't yes she
should take these pictures and yes she
is a star and like but she's tired but
she's tired and she works hard and
everyone like and everyone roasting her
and doing her on top of that I just felt
the need to defend really sad you know
what she's actually the last og of any
franchise right now um who's still on
the air look secular Kyle gets a ton of
respect like no one gives Ramona any
respect when it's like she's been
carrying New York on her seat on your
Jersey one so true and it just bothered
me and I'm not even like a Ramona State
I know but it's like have a little
respect is all I'm saying
I agree and then her third beef was with
Vicki who took what housewives on the
map and I know I've Ramona made some
good points Ramona like obviously it's
the OC because they were the first but
Ramona made some good points like New
York really brought it to a level of
celebrity and it made it a franchise
like it wasn't just a one-off show like
now it was a whole thing yeah but like
once you're in New York like it's New
York I make it here you can make it
anywhere in any franchise and I'm gonna
be able to argue that if the first
spread tries had been Beverly Hills
cause it's like Beverly Hills but Orange
County it's like it's a small town it's
not like the capital like people refer
to New York and LA is like you know the
capital of the world you know the house
of potin no one's gonna say that about
Orange County so it's like they made it
more of like a cosmopolitan the global
show yeah I just I felt like she wasn't
she wasn't wrong Vicki wasn't wrong but
like Ramona had Cimmerian they were
exactly what she's so crazy I'm like
give the woman some respect did you feel
like anti did a good job of like
wrangling everyone he did it's a lot it
was a lot they did a good job they also
did a good job of turning people's mics
off quickly because like people are in
the back talking but you didn't hear
thing other than like who was on stage
so true the optics must have been like
like 77 mics right and also it's like
usually you're gonna contain two studio
that his watch opens live studio is so
tiny there's like no audio there's no
echo like they were like in a 2000
person theater yeah
also they mentioned that Judge Joe
Giudice had said that New Jersey put the
house eyes on the map oh yeah
and in a way the he didn't put them on
the map but like in the way he wasn't
he's not wrong about the fact that like
what happened in New Jersey just took it
to another level it took it to a more
mainstream level like it wasn't as Nishi
anymore because it was in the news like
on in the New York Times yeah Robert was
never like the table flipping took the
franchise to Anna but everything
elevates it to the point where we're at
Bravo con it's not just one person well
sure in isolation other than and eco and
it's not just Vicki Gunvalson that's why
but it's everything is a step into the
ecosystem yes so I just just justice for
Ramona which is something I never
yeah we met the new housewife of New
York Leah McSweeney you guys haven't
watched yet I didn't record so it was on
a - am i saying so I will watch when I
get home I just got like a really good
vibe from her because she came out she
was wearing Virgil off-white like very
cool and she wasn't like fazed by
anything she like took her time to
answer the questions didn't say much and
just seemed like sure of herself
that's so nice like you can come on to
the show well I can be a jules Weinstein
and like be totally irrelevant like a
blimp on the radar or you be Leah
McSweeney who like gets to be introduced
at Bravo come like that's so prestigious
it's really all about timing you know
it's really all about his head that's
like but even I you dated Leah McSweeney
like never becomes a star like whatever
she got to be introduced at Bravo come
like that's it it was such a big deal
and like that's awesome that's how I
feel about the Salt Lake City launch
it's like it's a huge launching pad like
everyone is so excited and that's why
Brava Khan should be I don't know if it
should be a yearly thing maybe a every
other year thing like the Olympics but I
just think it's such a cool way to
announce like and I think a lot of times
TV networks will announce their shows
that like an upfront which is like a
corporate event it's like boring like
this is so cool it's like for the people
by the people like the people who'd be
excited about her in the audience I
think that I definitely agree it makes
it more but it's like I'm more excited
than I think I would be if it was just
announced like on Twitter you know right
and it's like we just got that new show
Texa con us and it's like where did that
go oh yeah Majan that was announced at
Bravo calm like we would be talking
about it we'd be excited yeah like Real
Housewives of San Antonio vibes like
we'd be there
excites me right so so yeah it was it
was really cool to see everyone everyone
looked great and it's just like a
pageant and I can't believe only two
people were wearing the same thing I
know it was a marriage medicine
intensely and Tinsley yeah well Tinsley
has like basic style that's what they
always say like everyone like goes like
she got her dress from intermix it's
like everyone's just gonna say Tinsley
literally goes to intermix and just pies
off the mannequin right but so so many
of them do I mean not everyone Erika
Jayne wearing custom pretty mess yeah
but some of them have actually a lot of
stylists and only um only MJ was wearing
the retro feat dress that's like taking
the world by storm but Kyle wore it
another day
odd Robert machine Jordan emerald and
she's also worn it previously
yeah but you would think like everyone
would but I have that dress it is the
best most fun MJ looks amazing in it um
oh my god she looks incredible
I don't know it's Sisterhood of the
Traveling dress it fits everyone and
everyone looks [ __ ] snatch in it like
big boobs little boobs like everyone
looks good yeah I haven't tried it on
yet so I for some reason I feel like I'm
gonna look at me but you could try mine
on because I know yes it's technically a
large but it's like one of those things
like it just it's magical in size fits
all if it's ever no Mercedes was the
snatchler and she had she was wearing
the baby blue version of the dress with
her hair in a high ponytail or a new and
she just looked so [ __ ] adorable and
I actually think Kyle might have been
wearing retro-futuristic wasn't the same
color so they weren't wearing the same
dress I'm just saying it's crazy that no
one else was wearing because there are
so few places that like out you have to
stuff right and pretty much everyone
chops it like revolve so ya revolve
forward intermix
intermix etcetera um real husband Lana I
would get through quickly cuz I know you
don't watch but I know a lot of toasters
do you like hearing your recaps so um
what happened this week Nene made her
first appearance it's been three
episodes and she just now got here she
is not a good terms with literally
anyone but what's really cool is that
um they filmed at pride so Eva mmm
Cynthia and Nene all got to go to world
Pride on the Bravo float and and he was
on for the first time ever he was on a
real housewife show he was talking to
Nene he was like I'm sorry we put don't
be tardy on the playlist and she said
that no mean camera cool it was actually
really funny to see all the Margaret
Joseph's was on the episode like it was
cool to see other men I mean everyone
will happen with Bravo Conde yeah both
Beverly Hills oh is a New Yorker
right now did they feel my brother come
like I feel like there has to be drama
from Bravo I hope so yeah it was really
cool and so Nene and actually was also
really cool is that Cynthia's daughter
came out as fluid so she came out on the
show was like actually really like cool
and Cynthia was like so cool about it
was really like a handbag I'm like your
daughter comes out of slick here's how
you'd handle it and then she brought her
children to pride it was really cool
like a nice full circle moment but Nene
and Cynthia haven't seen each other
they've been both talking [ __ ] about
each other um and literally they lock
eyes on the float and the episode ends
it's so annoying like they haven't seen
each other in Liberty's probably since
the reunion they lock eyes on the float
and then the episode ends it was so
annoying but I'm just like I know Porsha
is very controversial but I just stand
her so hard like I think she's such a
good mom I think she's going through it
and I really love her I'm just like
watching her and then like Kenya who's
also like going through it Kenya it's
like her life is so fake like there's a
whole rumor that she paid this man to be
her husband and baby daddy and like I
couldn't agree more like he is so
disliked he does the first time he's
actually been in the house and he's been
working he's just like so just in so
mean to her like it's actually kind of
sad because she's like he just like
judges her for like not being like it's
good like he's like he's just like
judges everything she does when being a
mother [ __ ] frustrating I love Kenya
and I also love Porsha I just want to
say don't you think that someone who had
to hire a man to be her husband and her
baby I think might also be going through
it no totally but it's like she's not
being open and honest I got think a lot
like she's a wall up wears like you're
on a reality show like I think that's
why people didn't like her the first
go-around this she's just so like kind
of calculated and like she lets you see
what you want her to see where I was
like no Porsha setting cameras in her
house and it's a mess and the baby and
she's crying she does I make about it
the baby [ __ ] his pants like that's real
motherhood and like that's what it's
like to be an authentic reality star
totally but I'm like imagine what Kang
was going through and she's putting on a
brave face and she's acting strong and I
know comes off his fake but like she's
like no because it's like it's starting
to unravel like she's like they're gonna
go to therapy like she starts crying but
like I even feel like that's fake like I
can't explain it like I really just
think about what she must actually be
going yeah no but for sure but it's like
you're not letting me and so I can't
relate okay I just think that like
Porsha is and I know it's so crazy
because people think the exact opposite
opposite is me people think portes just
so fake but it's like real I think she's
so wrong everyone saying they stand
Porsha I stamp Porsha so hard and that's
like on Twitter like it's very
controversial but I really can't put a
controversial yeah but it's like this is
like opposite day this franchise has
been through in the last few years of
course
it's [ __ ] there like she is there and
she's there so I just I stand her and
and now we first saw Nene like literally
she doesn't leave her house it's so
crazy they films like a video for
American Cancer Society because Greg is
cancer free and it's so great and Nene
definitely has like this weight lifted
off of her but she's still so petty like
she's just she's talking about us she's
going through the spiritual awakening
but she's like talking [ __ ] about Porsha
on some podcast and this girl who has a
podcast I don't know if it's maybe a
radio show was called the morning
something it was crazy she is getting so
much airplay like it's so unfair like it
was called dumb morning and their two
chairs I was like she's it was The
Morning Post it was like in literally
the morning ghost like something crazy
like that um so it's like Nene's just
talking about if she's so different now
and like I really did I can let go of
what happened last season cuz she was
going through it like her husband in
cancer I'm like they were there marriage
was in shambles like I can actually
forget about it but it's like she's here
saying she's a new person but she's
still doing petty [ __ ] so it's like
maybe maybe you're not a new person like
maybe maybe I can't forgive um kandi is
just so boring like I just I like her
because she's like always there but she
stinks like she's so boring and like I
just don't I don't believe like I just
don't I'm just not I'm not here for it
IVA is like stirring the pot like it's
nobody's business she is like loving the
fact that Nene and Cynthia are not
friends because now she's like Cynthia's
best friend you know and their
friendship was like oh I'm stronger and
stronger you know and they really are
like really adding to each other and
they went to pride together but she's
just like living she is like she's
relevant now cuz there's like a lot
going on and I think that she actually
really needs the show cuz I know she
says she's not living above her means
but she definitely is also last thing
I'll say is I think of all the housewive
ensures we've ever had we have the best
tag line of all time Porsha you know she
coined the famous term by a she so she
went through a hard year she's a phoenix
rising from the ashes and her thing is
you know I don't want to I don't want to
yeah you don't want to botch a lot about
it because I put it on my story and I
botched it Porsha Atlanta tagline ashes
okay come on white leave me Porsha
dealerships in Atlanta hold on Porsha
Atlanta tagline okay
start getting them in like your time I'm
actually feeling looking forward to that
like okay okay ready have it this
Phoenix is risen and I'm saying bye
ashes so complex and it's like you think
about it's like a phoenix rising from
the ashes by a she by ashes like it's
actually saying this Phoenix and every
time I hear it on the intro I like laugh
this Phoenix has risen and I'm saying my
ashes it's so funny that's amazing yeah
bother her okay now we can talk about
Keeping Up with the Kardashians oh okay
great episode candy land theme I mean
you know guys know where aside on this
fight basically also just remind me I
want to talk to about the robbery thing
because not somebody Oh Penelope and
North are having enjoyed birthday party
the kids want and the candy land theme
Courtney happens to be the one
organizing mostly everything with Sharon
Sachs and but Kourtney doesn't want um
like candy because it's filled with
chemicals and red dye and it's gonna
kill you and make you age and she
shouldn't be feeding it to the kids and
she wants like organic options maybe
salad maybe you're counting cotton candy
I mean Kim's like no it's candy land
like we need candy and if you don't want
candy then change the seat you can't
have candy lane without candy yeah like
you don't need a salad bar yeah then
Kourtney like went behind Kim Zack and
told Sharon like no candy at the end of
the day they had candy and candy the
kids were all hyped up Kim said there
was way too much candy and matter like
oh my god like kids can I mean kids
there was so much candy but like there
didn't need to be that much candy but
like kids go to birthday parties they a
pizza and soda and cake and they're
hyped up like that's what happens at a
birthday party like it's it's not it's
not a CBD theme like they've been doing
it right nobody's are fine but Kim is so
old at school and her thinking that like
kids should be eating candy oh my god no
no like there's definitely a balance
like I definitely think that like we
know so much about candy like the
chemicals were like how are kids ever
gonna build immunity to diseases but
they can't eat candy
there were immunity to anything they can
eat any cake the boy in the plastic
bubble like totally it's so frustrating
and like I and did Yuri Courtney sweater
she was coming out yes she was she was
coming swinging and I just totally
disagreed with her like if you want if
you don't wanna have candy have a
different theme and that's all Kim was
saying like we can't have candy land
without candy like that's right let me
it's not like let's not make a lien
party let's just change with you yeah so
it all worked out the party was great
and came like admitted that she was
wrong and that there was too much candy
and all the kids
- hyped and the parents were like
freaking out but I think that's what
happens at birthday parties like if
they're not getting hyped on candy like
they're getting hyped on a petting zoo
either way they're excited because it's
a fun party yeah let the kids live can I
can a party just be a party apparently
not whose party was a for Penelope and
North and they're super close in age
yeah besties um so and you also saw Kim
was on Good Morning America with Jenna
Jenna Bush Hager yes I'm talking about
Rodney Reed and like when they first
posted a clip I actually now Stan
gentlemen shaker because when they first
posted a clip people were like coming
for Jenna Bush like Kim and honestly
Canada but she stood by Kim was like she
was less well-spoken like I love her and
then I watched the interview yesterday
it was like six minutes
he was so interesting it was Kim wore
that outfit - suddenly service I don't
think I've ever seen Kim in the same
outfit twice whatever I know I was
thinking the same thing she must've had
so much for - yeah it was a great
interview just talking about Rodney Reed
and she was really talking about how the
bipartisanship was like so inspiring
like people from Shaun King who is like
I think more liberal to Ted Cruz in
Texas like all rallying around this
whole case and I thought it was like so
and I said she really gave credit where
credit was due and then I saw this thing
on Twitter they're like really made me
upset because Shaun King has been like
the leader of this thing and he said
something about Kim someone commented on
his Instagram where I was Kim Kardashian
on The Today Show being interviewed
about this case and not you and he
responded because she likes being on TV
and I like doing the work it's a come on
we all work together to do it yeah so
there was AG and it's like yes I'm sure
Shaun King did more work than Kim
Kardashian don't get me wrong I was on
his email list I got emails from John
King like once a week but you can't deny
that like Kim being on this I put it on
the map and really globe made it like
this huge global story like just come on
we all we did it like let's celebrate
let's not come for each other right I
thought that was really like loser II
that is pretty lose me but I wonder if
they talked and maybe he wasn't they
were gonna go together and he was like I
don't wanna be on TV but then he was
shady about it shady no by the way now
if he had just said because she likes
being on TV and I don't okay I actually
could have understand that but and I
like doing the work that's insinuating
that she doesn't like to do the work
yeah we're the [ __ ] Cheney it's shady
and it's like I have a hard time
believing that Kim didn't do the work
because on the Today Show interview she
said that um she was with Rodney when he
found out so it's like she was in it you
know yeah just like a nobody who doesn't
know work and you don't get to sit next
to me when he finds out that he got 120
more days you know yeah you know that
just doesn't happen
it's also like such good news we haven't
spoken about it yet I know but celebrate
it's so great and Jenna Bush asked a
question she was like it was actually
like chilling she was like I forgot the
victim's name Stacy Stacy's both like
parent mom and sister both believe that
Rodney did it like does that change how
you feel and Kim's like no love her love
her she's really getting the unite this
country man she is oh my god she's just
talking about the bipartisanship like
that word I was like yes Kim you tell
him she's just my such a congressman
okay McHugh yeah you tell those
partisans I was like so here for it I
just really love her like I'm so
inspired by her I love her no it's
incredible also they are do they come up
with names games on this episode
oh and then it did end up releasing
those infomercials unless you're gonna
put it on her Instagram with the hashtag
add interest on yes very into the
sentence and they are so they had to
like change the labels and a lot of the
original products and now it was really
really looking smart how they did it
what they did is they're putting labels
on top of the kimono labels and some of
them and and it'll be clear that it was
like a rebrand but because now we've
seen the whole genesis on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians it's like now it
all makes sense and I don't like if I'm
getting my thing so she made it all work
and she's a [ __ ] genius and she is I
just be united we stand I just really
hope she follows in the footsteps like I
hope Spanx buys her for six hundred mil
you know I know I hope she just keeps I
hope that um I don't know what's like a
big company in fashion I hope Amazon
Visor yeah or like a Nordstrom yeah the
worst remnants like a part owner in good
America they've got their own problems
you know do the retail yeah but they're
killing it like they have there's a
brand new Nordstrom on 57th Street it's
[ __ ] huge yeah so again in tableaus I
do need to get there maybe that's good
place to shop before Utah even if
someone told me it's like a store with
no clothes this is brand new it's like I
haven't heard that okay um but speaking
of shopping we have some fun patron
videos that we're gonna be shooting this
week and we are doing a patron episode
today a much requested episode about
planners planning scheduling how
organizing busy schedules all organized
yeah
like how we plan yeah I'm so excited to
talk about it show you some planners go
back in my planning plans yeah I'm just
here to tell you like how it what not to
do and Jackie's here to tell you what to
do do what to do yes so we'll be
recording that today I will be taking
your questions soon had to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast and
then we're gonna be in Utah all next
week you know using our family and
creating content having such a great
time all will be available on patreon
but there are no episodes of the morning
shows next week because we are taking of
a ship and we're so freaking excited
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning to us the Millennium morning
show where we go live Monday to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to give this video a thumbs up
on YouTube please subscribe we're also
available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
iTunes Spotify stitcher Public Radio I
our video casts box or they've we love
you guys so much thank you so much for
being here we appreciate you and we hope
you have a great day we'll see you
tomorrow bye bye
you